[Musique]
une journée d'information pour ces
jeunes pour la plupart tout juste
bachelier qui souhaitent poursuivre des
études supérieures à la réunion ou en
mobilité sur un même site s'est réuni
l'ensemble des partenaires boursiers et
opérateur de la mobilité comme ladom le
crous la région et le département de la
ring grain et quelques informations pour
les nombreux en étant non boursiers faut
voir si ça a changé depuis cinq ans les
bourses du coup là je cherche un master
en métropole j'attends les réponses et
je suis venu ici pour récolter des
informations par rapport aux aides en
fait des renseignements pour l'apl ou si
je peux avoir aussi des aides
vu que c'est la première fois j'ai
étudié en france cette cinquième journée
d'information s'est tenue au théâtre de
champ fleuri des conférences ont
également permis des échanges entre les
différents partenaires le département
présente ses quatre grands dispositifs d
aide aux études supérieures
les dispositifs phares sont la bourse
départementale c'est une aide financière
qui est accordé sous condition de
ressources la location de scolarité qui
concerne plutôt les étudiants qui sont
inscrits dans des parcours d'excellence
dits d'excellence des écoles de
commerces des écoles de management des
parcours d'ingénieur par exemple et puis
nous avons d'autres dispositifs comme
bénéficions d'une
le droit de réservation pour 85 cents à
la cité internationale universitaire de
paris donc possibilité pour ceux qui
sont dans des niveaux master master 1
master 2 d'accéder à ces chambres à
paris et enfin le dernier dispositif
c'est la bourse doctorale
mais là qui concerne des étudiants qui
sont inscrits à la réunion à
l'université de la réunion et qui
travaillent sur des thèses des
thématiques correspondant aux
compétences du département
pour retrouver l'ensemble des
informations relatives aux aides
départementales
une seule adresse le www.net tirer
bourse points 0
[Musique]